there are so much distraction available
to you out there that if you are not
acutely careful it will dominate your
days Friday afternoon few minutes make
yourself a short three category priority
list for the next week I want you to
find 15 minutes today and I want you to
slow down wanna be happy
build a life not just the business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how you can be
more productive using these simple hacks
okay let's kick it off with hack number
one make a three category priority list
with Laura Vander Kim
Fridays can be the most productive day
of the week I know it doesn't seem like
they could be the most productive day of
the week but they can be I know it often
happens Friday afternoon if you're
working on Monday through Friday
schedule you're kind of sliding into the
weekend at that point maybe even hiding
out so nobody finds you it's really hard
to start anything new on Friday
afternoon but you might be willing to
think about what future you should be
doing and if you spend a little bit of
time on Friday afternoons planning the
week ahead
you can turn what might be wasted time
into your most productive minutes of the
week so Friday afternoon few minutes
make yourself a short three category
priority list for the next week career
relationships self making a three
category list reminds you that there
should be something in all three
categories so that right there is gonna
nudge you to plan a more balanced week
and have a more balanced life it doesn't
have to be long just a few short things
in each but look at your week see where
they can go front load the week if you
can do as much of it as you can Monday
and Tuesday because you know what
stuff's gonna come up it could be good
stuff could be bad stuff but by planning
the week ahead and putting what matters
to you into your schedule first you
vastly increase the chances that that
stuff gets done pack number two slow
down with Mel Robbins for many of us
slowing down is really scary but that's
exactly what you need to do and so if
you are always in a rush if you feel
like there's urgency in your life if you
move at a pace that makes you feel
panicked or rush you've got a million
things to do and you think that you're
busy
you're not productive the solution is
not doing more it's doing less it's not
speeding up it's actually slowing down
because being busy doesn't mean you're
in control it means you're being driven
by this fear of slowing down you're
being driven by the fear that when you
slow down you're gonna have to confront
where you're at and you're gonna have to
start doing the work and that be can be
scary but you take control of your life
not by speeding up everybody but by
slowing down you take control of your
life by removing distraction and adding
in focus you take control of your life
by being honest with yourself about the
things that you're filling your life
with it doesn't matter that makes you so
busy and that also prevents you from
finding the 15 minutes that you need
every day to really find the courage to
focus on making your life a little bit
better or pushing something forward if
you're somebody who's guilty of being
busy and never having the time to do the
thing that really matters to you that
your hearts calling you to do or you
never have the time to do something to
take care of yourself I want you to find
15 minutes today and I want you to slow
down
whether you've always thought about
meditating and you've never done it
download the combat listen to it do one
guided meditation go for a walk for 15
minutes just to quiet walk without your
phone or with your phone turned off have
a cup of tea or a cup of top coffee and
read something listen to a podcast for
15 minutes take a bath tonight something
where you experience the sensation of
slowing down because again busyness
becomes a habit and when it becomes a
habit it becomes an epidemic and when it
becomes an epidemic it will rob you of
your ability to take control of your
life and at the root cause of all of
this is fear just the fear of slowing
down because when you slow down and you
start to create priorities and you start
to take control now you're responsible
for what's happening in your life and
you can no longer rely on just
complaining that you're busy also if you
want to have more self love and
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join our
but you might want to get honest with
yourself like instead of doing this be a
billionaire or do this do you really
because you can make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
I've been at a point in my life where I
thought I thought less of me than anyone
thought of me how many you been there a
lot of the anxiety that we feel is
actually due to using words that are not
defined very well hack number three beat
the Sun up with Grant Cardone grant rant
of the day the one you need to live with
wake up to every day is that right there
okay beat the Sun up folks you got to
beat the Sun up if you can't beat up the
roll up of the Sun up you're gonna get
beat up in life okay I've been doing
this for a long time now say beat that
thing up that monster out there that
warms this planet that nourishes and
gives us light you can't live it to the
next life if you're not beating the Sun
up so many of you complain about how
much time you have you don't have time
man because you don't beat the Sun up
get started early and when you get
started early that means you need to
shut it down early okay shut it down or
at least so you get sleep I was I was I
was asleep last night at nine o'clock so
I could beat the scent up the market
this morning and see the world wake up
with me pack number four use the 9091
rule with Robin Sharma so for the next
90 days your first 19 minutes at work
make it focused on your single most
important project I'll repeat that again
for the next 90 days the first 90
minutes of your workday focus
monomaniacal e on your single most
valuable project I call it your game
changing move so it might be it might be
creating a new piece of code that will
revolutionize the marketplace it might
be a new product that when you
launched it will fill a need within your
industry that no peer is currently
providing I don't know what your game
changing move is but this is your poetry
this is your magnum opus for the next 90
days so what most people do is you know
people who are playing at victimhood
people who are in the ninety five
percent people who are making excuses
about ordinary results in their life a
lot of them are not doing the things
that would give them legendary results
and what they do is they get to the
office and rather than using prime time
for a activities they use their best
hours watching dancing cats on whatever
it is whatever the video platform is
they spend their best hours surfing the
internet looking at blogs they spend
their best hours playing with
notifications reading notifications
chatting with friends who are not really
their friends but really they're just
bored so they're distracting themselves
which is just a form of medication
because potential unexpressed turns to
pain and they're in a lot of pain and
it's subconscious and they haven't done
the work to know it so really they've
created these drugs of choice like too
much email too much web surfing too much
chit chatting too much looking at funny
looking videos that make them laugh in
the moment that make them feel happy and
give them a short burst of dopamine and
maybe a little bit of serotonin which is
the pleasure neurotransmitter and that's
how they get through their day and all
I'm saying is there's so much
distraction available to you out there
that if you are not acutely careful it
will dominate your days for the next 90
days your first 90 minutes create a
tight bubble of total focus so that no
one can distract you turn off your
devices put them in a little plastic bag
put some reminders on your door maybe
some post-it notes that this is my type
bubble of total focus for the next 90
minutes tell your team tell your loved
ones maybe get it put a Do Not Disturb
sign on your door they'll laugh and
explain it to them that for the next 90
days I will spend 90 minutes away from
distraction away from technology away
from interruptions
focusing on my magnum opus focusing on
the genius project that I want to bring
into the world because I will never mail
it in I will always bring it on and I'm
gonna do this for the next 90 minutes
and I'm gonna optimize it and iterate it
every day and I'm gonna bring my full
bandwidth because what makes a genius
they all have one trait in common they
were able to spend extended periods of
time in isolation focused mono
maniacally on their most valuable
project and hack number five the last
one before a very special bonus hack is
use the batching technique with Tim
Ferriss so what is badging to explain it
in simplest terms we can talk about
laundry all right so you wouldn't do
your laundry every time you have a new
pair of dirty socks you wait for a
certain critical mass of dirty laundry
to accumulate and then you do the
laundry
why same with the post office if you
have many different types of mail
they're gonna come together you need to
mail you're gonna wait for a certain
critical mass as opposed to just going
there for every single letter because
there's a set-up cost there is a task
switching cost getting the car driving
there spending the gas spending the time
laundry putting it all together
detergent and so on right so the the
time and labor involved in doing one
letter or twenty or one pair of socks or
entire basket of clothing is the same
and you want to be both effective and
efficient with your allocation of
resources ie time if you apply those to
business you can apply them in a million
and one different ways and I'll give you
a few examples one of the most common I
suppose directional questions or
specifics that I'm asked about is
frequency well do I batch on a daily
basis do I batch on a weekly basis do I
batch on a monthly or quarterly basis
and the answer is I do all of those
things but you don't have to try it all
at once and I would not encourage you do
that I would encourage you to perhaps
try out one or two approaches and see
what works for you this is a very
personal set of techniques you develop a
portfolio that works for yourself let me
tell you a few things that I and others
do for instance you might decide that on
a given day
from the time you wake up until lunch is
your primary creation period this could
be writing it could be recording could
be anything that is proactively creative
and synthesis then once you have lunch
you are permitted to do administrative
tasks phone calls email triage
calendaring and so on I do this quite a
lot particularly from Tuesday to
Thursday on certain weeks on a weekly
basis I know the CEO of a very
well-known startup pretty much everyone
watching this would know this company
and instead of batch on a daily basis
looking at his week Monday to Friday
he might have day one administrative
tasks day two HR hiring day three
product day for marketing and on each of
those days he will focus on thematically
or categorically those types of tasks
that is yet another approach and very
commonly I will batch phone calls on
Mondays and Fridays and in I was even
broadly speaking this is voice related
tasks so I will have phone calls and
podcast recording on Mondays and Fridays
and this helps to prevent also
interruptions and task switching that
can result if you have miscellaneous
phone calls and podcasts scattered
throughout the week makes it very
difficult to do deep work on anything
that might require three to five hours
of uninterrupted time I am on a
quarterly basis you could look at batch
producing or completing certain types of
normally scattered activities for
instance I am recording this video right
now during a content generation week
where a week is blocked out once per
quarter to focus on answering common
questions that all of you or my readers
or listeners have asked and so on and so
forth on a say six-month - yearly basis
I have started in the last few years
batching travel why would I batch travel
and there many different reasons to
batch travel
one of my reasons is that I want to
practice being off the grid for extended
periods of time to not only remind
myself and prove to myself that it is
possible to do that and know the
internet will not stop the universe will
not end if you are unavailable and
unreachable for certain periods of time
and also to rejuvenate to recharge being
away from social media and keyboards and
laptop screens and so on batching is one
of the fundamental concepts that you
need to understand if you understand the
principle the reasons for the concepts
you can come up with your own examples
to experiment with and usually not
permanent changes think of them as
two-week experiments one tiny thing that
you can test with assuming that it's on
a daily or weekly basis and try it out
see what works keep what works reject
what doesn't add what is uniquely your
on borrowing from Bruce Lee with that
and before you know it you will have a
reliable dependable way of making
yourself more effective and more
efficient which is your bespoke
iteration of magic now I have a special
bonus cup from Dan Locke on how to get
more productive that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that is time for
the three-point landing questions let's
go from just watching a video to take in
action here we go question number one
what is gonna be on your three category
priority list number two how can you
apply the 9091 rule and number three
where can you use the batching technique
the entire computer you're working on it
let's say two three four hours straight
non-stop you notice how you lose focus
and you have to teak yeah right
productivity you can see like at first
like yeah first hour but then even
you're doing the work but after a few
hours you're like you can see you feel
you know your party is going down after
like four five hours right hey how long
we've been here anyway 37 minutes yeah
so cuz human beings we're not designed
to do that
how breaking all that we actually
designed the way that we work it's more
like a like a sprint right so what
intensely could be 40 45 minutes 50
minutes yes right
then do another 45-minute brick right
that's how I you gotta look him in you
to schedule your time we're not designed
to work five six hours trick no brick
you know you're not your pro tippity
right you're not very productive after
few hours because we have not designed
that's why we lose focus and you kind
you kind of see the self blurry in front
of you you know you're not as sharp
you're not as Cloris
if you want to learn how to activate
your beast mode check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there when you're willing to
take control of your environment and put
yourself through the stressors required
for adaptation you literally can become
anything